certains se sont installés depuis hier
soir aux abords du palais de justice de
paris
la place est chère pour les équipes de
télévision françaises mais surtout
étrangère c'est que le moment est
supposé être d'importance
mohamed al fayed en personne est à paris
pour assister lui aussi à la
confrontation générale il ya tellement
de preuves d'éléments différents que
j'espère que le juge parviendra à dire
lesquels sont justes pour reconstituer
ce qui s'est passé vous êtes confiant
par rapport à cette confrontation où il
ya toujours de l'espoir quand on croit
en dieu
l'espoir que dieu trouvera la vérité
pour nous depuis peu moins man al fayed
a décidé de parler aux caméras
c'est lui qui aurait souhaité venir à la
confrontation à ses côtés d'autres
parties civiles sont là la mère de la
princesse diana et les parents du
chauffeur de la mercedes henri-paul seul
travers lui jones l'unique rescapée
toujours amnésique est absent un à un
les photographes sont convoqués à la
barre à chaque fois ils sont confrontés
avec les témoins présents sur les lieux
de l'accident comme le docteur maille
est le premier à avoir soigné diana lui
a toujours dit que les photographes ne
l'avait pas gêné dans son travail
d'autres témoins parlent en revanche
d'une attitude agressive de la part des
photographes
c'est pour y voir définitivement plus
clair que la confrontation qui durera
toute la journée a été organisée